hey guys it is Tuesday the 15th up
September today my name's Jess McDonald
and you're watching gamespot knees the
PlayStation press conference kicked off
Tokyo Game Show this year and here's all
the good stuff that came out of it to
get you all caught up in other hardware
news a new ps4 HDD edition was revealed
with awesome colored face plates along
with new ps4 controller colors Japan are
also set to get a 12-percent price drop
for the ps4 down to the equivalent of
292 us box which will go into effect on
October 31 a whole bunch of games were
announced including kingdom hearts HD
two point eight which Square Enix have
said will include an HD remake of
Kingdom Hearts dream Drop Distance
Kingdom Hearts key back cover and
Kingdom Hearts Oh point2 birth by sleep
other games on the horizon include
danganronpa 3 4 ps4 and Vita cold
fighting game the king of fighters 14
gravity rush to as well as gravity rush
remastered for ps4 Sega also came out to
announce they are making Yakuza six for
ps4 while Capcom revealed resident evil
Umbrella core a competitive shooter set
in the resident evil universe that will
come to ps4 that may seem like an awful
lot of news but Sony wasn't done there
we also finally got a look at blood
bonds first expansion the expansion
entitled blood-borne the old hunters
will tell the story of the legendary
hunters from the main game although it's
set in a nightmarish world where hunters
from the past of trapped forever not
cool the expansion will feature new
stages outfits NPCs weapons and magic
there are also set to be new bosses for
you to take on including Ludwig who
appears in the game's law the expansion
will be available on November 24 for
twenty bucks finally a massive update
has landed for GTA 5 and here's all the
new mischief you can get up to the
latest update brings the Rockstar editor
to consoles and introduces free mode
events to GTA online these free mode
events which are only available on ps4
xbox one and pc are essentially events
that trigger in the game
world when you encounter them so they
will not have loading screens for
lobbies there are more than 10 of them
in GTA online currently one of which is
titled hunt the Beast where you get all
werewolf esque and other players need to
take you down you can check out a full
rundown of the events available right
now on site the update also adds to
adversary modes called cross the line
and hunting pack and introduces a whole
mess of fixes and tweaks let me know
down in that comment box what mattered
to you today and be sure to head to
gamespot where we've got all the latest
out of TGS as well as our destiny the
taken King review in progress that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today as always let me know what
mattered to you in that comment section
and i'll catch you same time tomorrow